7 8 10 11 30 all right back to pipe
inning smash punch I'm trapped now in
this creation of my own mind output wow
that animation is on par with the last
of us Alyssa joke you made about a guy
stuck in an elevator I still is what Oh
can't stand the pipe America it's the
toughest weapon and all of existed we
stopped telling me about stupid things
all I broke my pipe Oh check this out
check the prime time [ __ ] um yeah I
just made that Jill just me I made that
joke so hard you all the TV turn ah this
is what my sitting here playing terrible
news just sitting here playing video
games with me ah
it's not as awesome of a curb stomp is
dead space Wow oh yeah we beat up though
it's good oh I beat up everything I
guess beat up that door imma beat up
this med pack be up the brick wall ah
that would really hurt your hands in
Turin note it made anything is like
valve puzzles this game was actually
half life 3 they're going for a very
artsy approach to the new moon oh look
there's a helicopter let's get to it
what is this place anyway such a crap
chain yeah yeah haha it's Detroit
Detroit look you walk into Detroit this
is the first thing you see is bodies
covered in the Venom symbiote yeah yep
that's what that is this is going to
traduce oh crap ow my brain is being bad
brain MV i'ma throw a brick at that yeah
whoo is that supposed to do something
yeah stopped the signal it stops the
signal the signal that's making everyone
go crazy become homeless it's a signal
that's made by the devil it's called the
devil signal you can have done something
better than just a signal i can meet you
i'll look there's carnage he's the devil
is put in the tank our date it's just an
alarm yep now I'm going to have fun
editing the sound for this so that you
can be heard by the audience unless
you're actually incredibly loud into the
microphone to what you might be okay so
later in this game you fight a guy in
iron man steampunk outfit on a boat with
a brain device and magnets and you have
superpowers you can scream so loud they
eat big lou's heads experience
you think I'm making this up not this
height good pork school this is actually
a playthrough spider-man web of shadows
okay look I don't want to think of it
hike oh no explosions oh oh no run
actually it has assisted me similar to
our camp all dresses really similar is
it a recent one no it wasn't ah
probably spider-man 2 because that's the
best superhero game app also skeletons
covered in the Venom symbiote that you
can kill one hit and in father yeah get
on my level son I can't see what I'm
getting
do I go
I guess you could say I'm loss is that
it's kind of did reference yep it makes
it makes better sense in the video that
people are watching right now you and I
are just watching a video game up that
was the off the reference here's a
skeleton man and I can here we go ha oh
my blackjack you should of him by the
way I don't have an index finger on my
left hand okay yup its plot from the
first game it gets cut off by this by
the devil your new demon be peachy it's
not ghosts it's nanobots gonna reference
move it's not referencing metal gear
everything everything invented
everything email gear can be explained
man well that's because there's so
there's a lot of references you can make
the metal gear because everything ever
happens in those games it's not like a
spy thriller game or a superhero game or
a survival thing game snake snake eater
take that game here draft and all up
there's crouch nope yes is there a
project what this trash can is driving
you nuts
Nick eater you walk around and hit
things with this awesome pipe and we
finished that's how you finish the level
yup you just get off just kill stuff
until you run out of stuff to kill
clearly it was this way all store open
is this deck can I just live in this
dumpster shout out to people who live in
hoboken on my mug it's like it's a valve
climbing puzzle clearly the comically
you ever strangle the skeleton it hurts
your hands there's a lot of sharp edges
it's like those crab legs I
one person in the world will get that oh
look perhaps a ladder oh no my pipe no
come back you bastard I gave you
everything you leave me like this while
Lucky's climbing a ladder like a person
instead just sliding up up it without
using his hands let's stop most video
games go down
whoa like 11 2009 some point it's gabi
2008 there will be big letters on the
screen saying what so this is scary
right just punching everything and never
time because you're so top true yo are
you remember how scared you were you
would he played this and was terrified
yup let's use that a car the scene
someone with this prosthetic arm oh look
wheelchairs is his survival horror
remember brought you I'm a break your
legs with the crunch then give you the
crunch so you can walk and then it'll be
fair fight then I can break your other
leg boot I'm back here oh it's a closet
it's a magic closet so i know i love
this game member oh hey oh look a
homeless guy hand yup
that guys like cartoonishly evil he
sounds like sounds like Skeletor yeah
that's how fast or what so are you just
so bored you're gonna die over there
list Eureka play hahaha should be
interested should be a poison him yep
that's they have fun you gotta go press
that green light mmm maybe look there's
a homeless guy go snack and good it's
better then the whole that's a storyline
you note that venom all you broke your
crunch think it's safe to say he's dead
man you press the proj mutton in halo
you kick in the same
we ran out of things to talk about it's
just us two beating up homeless people
yeah oh no you could done an
environmental kill if he's on his knees
you pick him up and then just throw them
in this stuff you could throw them into
that baby crib and then I'd make a cool
job Oh pipe yeah go dispense justice
with your steel pipe of justice oh
alright crawl into this web of shadows
that was another it i'm referencing the
same thing like six times ok just don't
you died you're the worst you're the
worst hole puncher there ever was